so if you had the misfortune of seeing a
trailer for Dream House like I did
before you actually saw the movie you
found out a giant plot twist in the film
so for that reason I'm not going to be
showing the trailer in this review so
like I said in my intro I I just hate
the trailer for this movie it gave away
a plot twist that doesn't happen till
almost an hour into the film rooted a
huge surprise I'm not showing it in my
review don't see the trailer if you
haven't seen the trailer yet avoid it
please
dream house stars Daniel Craig Rachel
Boz Naomi Watts and it's a story about
the this distant couple and Craig Rachel
wise they move into this house they have
two little girls Naomi Watts lives
across the street saw ways given them
weird looks looking at him strange not
understanding you know why are they
there what's going on and she you know
you don't really know what's going on
there strange things start to happen in
kids say that they see people appearing
in the windows at night there are sounds
in the basement apparently someone
killed someone there at some point in
time big mystery and that's all I'm
saying this is a really messy movie and
it really seems like there was a problem
with the production on this movie
similar to Daniel Craig's movie the
invasion with Nicole Kidman which is
strange because this has an Abby Watts
who reminds me Nicole Kidman
you know me watch I think it's
incredibly much hotter it seemed like
behind the scenes this movie that there
was people not understanding exactly
where they wanted to go because it has a
good director Jim shared and he's made
some good films in the past Daniel Craig
Naomi Watts Rachel Weisz these are all
people who when they read a script
they're not going to be like oh yeah
sure whatever I'll do it they are good
actors and so I have a feeling there
were some problem the production of this
movie because this is a really sloppy
messy film however I do really like
scary films and this isn't so much like
a scary movie so much as it is kind of a
suspense film and the trailer makes it
seem like it's gonna be more you know of
course but it's a little more low-key
and subtle which is nice I like Daniel
Craig in the film I like his performance
more in the last half of the phone it's
just that there were certain parts of
this movie where the script was just
completely messed up certain things just
didn't mesh things didn't seem like they
worked out things didn't seem I
they fit a lot of liberties were taken I
enjoyed watching this film though and
it's because I like the actors involved
with it I like some of their ideas I
liked what they were trying to do but
there were so many aspects to this movie
that just didn't seem like they really
tried and it's not the actors fault it's
just kind of standard I guess the movie
is it's a very standard film it's one of
those movies where you're kind of
interested in the idea of what they have
and the plot and this story is kind of
interesting but it's so standard lead
made that you feel like I don't know
like it's just I was interested in where
the story was going I wanted to see what
was going to happen but there was
nothing really about the film that
really grabbed me and made me invested
I'm going to give the film a b-minus
okay now I'm going to explain this he
was never bored by this movie and I
liked the performances and I liked some
of the ideas behind the movie and some
of the plot things that happen later
I thought work out of neat but the movie
is made so mediocrity it's just such a
excited is that even a word out well it
didn't have any Flair or anything if
you're going to have something that you
just want to do some night and watch a
scary movie and just not care dream
house might be that movie it's just
trying to be something it's not so I'm
going to give Dreamhouse of d-minus if
you liked my review you can subscribe to
my channel and get stuck my eyes